[Applause]
is leading an alliance of six opposition
parties they don't all agree on policy
but they're united in one aim to bring
down hungary's prime minister viktor
orban
makizai is telling his people that orban
has split the country he's made his
close supporters rich and he's moving
more towards the autocracy of russia and
his friend president vladimir putin
rather than abiding by the eu's rule of
law
the war in ukraine dominates this
campaign makizay wants to back nato when
the eu in helping ukraine with military
aid but orban is telling his people the
opposition wants to join the war
it's a disgusting lie but urban has been
doing this forever i could say that he
has all the instead of protecting the
nation protecting the country he has
always been attacking the opposition for
12 years orban has been waging war on
everybody homosexuals the lgbtq
community roma migrants leftists
brussels orban has been waging war
forever he's been serving putin's
interest
maggie zai is from the provincial town
of hodmetovasha hay
where he organised a national movement
to unify political parties peter
marquissai is hardly a high-profile
politician he's mayor of a town known
mostly for its unusually long name he
isn't a member of parliament he doesn't
belong to a political party yet he's
posing the biggest threat yet to victor
orban
the two men do have one thing in common
though
they're both conservatives
orban disputes that he brands marquis i
and his alliance as left-wing
the left thinks that ukraine fights our
war this is what the leader of our
opponent said word for word that ukraine
fights our war this is a mistake this is
not our war in this war we cannot gain
anything but can lose everything
orban tells his people he'll keep them
safe and throws in sweeteners tax cuts
capped petrol prices and securing
russian gas supplies
on ukraine the government says it's
welcomed more than half a million of its
refugees
more than any other european country of
its size
that claim is described as misleading
though by at least one human rights
organization saying most of the refugees
are in transit
on the eve of voting marquis zai staged
his final push to try to buck the trend
of opinion polls giving orban an
increasing lead
but whatever the opposition says they
struggle to dissuade many hungarians
from seeing orban as a strong figure of
stability in dangerous times
andrew simmons al jazeera budapest